- On the surface the
dap does look like any,
everyday handshake, but
the dap is a gesture
of solidarity.
It's not just a handshake.
I'm Lamont Hamilton, I'm a
interdisciplinary artist.
I've been looking at
the handshake, the dap,
from a very specific and unique
African American experience.
It's a acronym for dignity and pride.
And it was coined by black soldiers
during the Vietnam war.
You have the ’60's and all
these political movements
and there's a racial
consciousness that was heightened.
- More power to the people!
- Now this war is happening and that moved
into this whole 'nother world.
You take these young men and you put them
in this space away from
home, they're gonna make
a home with each other,
and solidarity became really important.
So, that's where the dap was born out of,
was a communication
that, I'm not above you,
you're not above me, we're
side by side together.
And that's the original dap.
As black soldiers were coming home,
they were introducing this thing
that they did in ‘Nam to their friends.
And then that moves on and on and on,
and it is where it is today.
Five On The Black Hand Side
is a photographic series
in which I've been looking at the dap.
I've photographed about 120 handshakes.
Historical narratives
are very important to me,
but that kind of new imagining,
or new vantage point,
is what I'm interested in.
But I wanted to get at something deeper
than what the photographs
alone were doing.
Dapline is a performance piece.
We're really tryn' to
bring out that narrative
of black soldiers during the Vietnam war.
- I was always interested
in these really genuine,
but also complex expressions
within black culture.
Dapline became a visible
reflection of very quiet moments
between black men.
- The goal of what I'm
doing with the whole project
is to bring it back to
that very specific origin,
and give very specific and real credit
to this particular radical gesture
that has all this thing inside of it.
We have to recognize the black experience
as a truly American experience.
And then, what can I do to
move this narrative forward.